so true some challenges in the tech
industry I think it's what's known as
death by a thousand paper cuts
there was one thing on the other and it
always ended up with people wondering
why I was a woman why I was young and
you know why I was doing my own thing
people sort of assume that I am NOT
technical it can feel like you are
fighting against this believability
factor it hurts and it sort of puts this
doubt in your own mind saying should I
really not be here if I walk into a room
and I say that I'm an engineer and if I
don't look the way that a person is
expecting me to look then I kind of have
to prove to them that no no I am an
engineer and I know what I'm talking
about that's just the assumption the
default is that women of color can't be
technical aren't technical necessary so
we get treated like we are technical and
I begin to question myself and I know
that that is absolutely unacceptable and
it is completely untrue being in
environments where it's mostly men where
it's mostly white people there is a
psychic toll because I can't be my full
self there's always there's always a
little bit of needing to filter there's
always a little bit of a gap between
like what I'm actually like and what I
can be like and it's calculus that I do
every day it's it's exhausting
it's exhausting so there's no denying
the fact that there is gender disparity
I will try and qualify that with my own
experience
I really hate this one when people ask
me what I do even if they're the
implicit context is that everyone there
is an engineer they would always say
like what do you do there's this funny
thing that happens when someone goes to
that mental shift of realizing that you
actually are an engineer and then they
they kind of try to make up for it oh
good for you that's so great
wow I'm so surprised you're an engineer
which is such a backhanded compliment
because it means what does that even
mean the main thing was not having many
of my male counterparts treat me the
same way you know there are other male
friends with me or my husband and they
get asked the same question and they
don't receive the same reaction it just
makes me feel other it makes me feel
like I don't belong their training and
their biases and they'll prepare them to
encounter the black moment engineer
there are these tiny microaggressions
that happen when people know that you're
a person of color they want to know your
origin they want to know your they want
to know a bunch of things about you that
don't really matter when it comes to
your work it's very tough to explain to
someone what you experience if it's not
their lived experience because it
demands a sense of imagination imagine
you are nothing like how you are right
now
I've recently had a conversation with
the gentleman who asked me why should I
care why should I want to change it
what's in it for me it's this
interesting set of norms that are used
to sort of enforce who does well and who
doesn't do well in the tech industry and
as a result a lot of people end up being
hurt especially women people of color
people who have different sexual sexual
orientations there should be no one
group who gets to say what's in it for
me for an industry that is changing the
world right now the investment you make
in diversity and inclusion is in fact an
investment
everybody talks about diversity and
getting getting people in the door you
know we measure those numbers we don't
really talk much about the inclusion
part what are you doing to make sure
that everybody is included and feel safe
and supported and valued in your
organization it's going to end up and
your your work atmosphere being better
it's going to end up in healthier teams
it's going to end up and your products
being better what I really am hoping for
is that we as an industry don't
participate in or perpetuate the
systemic injustice is that we see in
society today and you can't really build
an app for everybody around the world if
everybody isn't in the room right
then there's this other side of the tech
culture in let's say a company like Yelp
that is working so hard to make sure
that we change the definition of what
tech culture means I think of openness
and collaboration I think of building
things and making sure that we help the
community and help the world you need
lots of different programmers who have
different backgrounds and different
ideas to come together and we can make
really great products without females so
many of the great work which has been
done would not be possible
females can really change the world and
not just engineering but in all other
aspects and no one should ever forget
that I love my job I love making stuff I
just want you know the industry to look
more like me and I think it will it just
will take time we are the so-called
smartest people in the world that's what
they keep telling us this is a problem
we can solve it it is important if these
need to be convinced of that please feel
free to come find me and I'll tell you
all the reasons why